we got mated as well with white pieces  so yeah  did not end well there are lots of well  everyone's strong in bike that's the  problem  yeah and yeah I think we'll see that  handshake any second now very very close  yeah repetition moves and I'm surprised  Magnus didn't take on uh ding in some  main lines just to at least ask the  question how much ding is willing to  reveal but  um yeah it looks like a decent antidote  to the London system well unless you  actually you know some years ago I would  feel like I'm joking here like you know  very droll haha but  you know for London does feel like it's  a bit of a main line for Magnus as well  like it's I think he plays it very  seriously it's not like it's a it's a  give up it's yeah  no true and there we do see the  handshake it is a draw